[Music]
Shannon I did not want to see you
tonight what happened they just they
they all turned on me they'll stab me in
the back and they saw me as a threat and
unfortunately some of them actually
don't know the game and I think I could
have been a really good ally in the
offer I made to him was gold and they
still didn't take it so good luck to
them this game is moving so fast do you
think that impacted how the strategy
played out for you well that definitely
impacted how I decided to play because
normally in a real season I would have
thrown the first bunch of competitions I
never would have come out swinging but
because it was going to go so fast I
mean I my boyfriend I talked long about
strategy and he's like you need to go
for it because maybe it'll give you a
chance in the beginning to create those
alliances if you're the first head of
household because it's a short season so
I tried it just didn't and that twist
messed me up too for sure oh for sure
the gift bag twist was lame I needed
another twist now I was waiting for him
like come on please a twist today and it
never came so well you had one vote in
your favor you know who that was yet I'm
gonna guess Marissa but I don't know it
was Brandi Glanville oh really okay
interesting she kind of wanted you to
stay after there was that tearful
conversation you guys had I tried I
tried a bunch of different things and
nobody was biting so I finally gave up
in terms of playing the game what
surprised you that you weren't expecting
I would talk to somebody as a friend
just like not even talking game and
somebody would see it and think oh
they're talking game they must be
aligned and I know they think that I was
working with James is some big final two
and I was strategizing against them and
I mean they're wrong and that wasn't
happening and they'll see it hopefully I
don't know what was shown but that's
what was frustrating to me is that I was
getting attacked for something I didn't
do
like at least it was something I did and
I got caught I could be like yeah I
sucked at that and I got caught but I
didn't do it so I'm not really sure what
she heard or
she saw who do you think is the next big
target in that house
James is definitely a target but I know
that they're also trying to use them and
work with him but I think the minute
they're able to try to like legitimately
get rid of him they probably will but
he's gonna win tonight's HOH so good
luck now you went in that house Marissa
was a real friend outside of the house
sort of I mean we were more acquaintance
acquaintances since because we work
together so maybe less shocking that she
turned on you then maybe viewers might
think I wasn't shocked I mean I never
really I mean I was surprised she wanted
to be an ally in the beginning to tell
you the truth that's not really what I
expected but I mean we didn't get to
know each other when we work together so
um but yeah I'm I'm definitely not happy
with her and Ross more than anything
even though Ari and Brandi were
responsible for this the fact that she
and Ross turned like and they kept
saying let's be friends outside the
house that's gonna take some time I'm
not ready for that yeah I'm ready for
you to go back and watch these episodes
and see the string-pulling yeah yeah I'm
definitely not happy with them
[Music]
you